I am also witnessing many many of my
friends leaving I just drove back from
the airport early this morning earlier
this morning there about five or six
moving trucks and I'm kind of counting
them now because I had a friend come
over last night tell me he's moving to
Florida and these are basically upper
middle class and wealthy people there
the tax base to this did it and I've
never wondered about you know since
maybe I stopped being a liberal I I
always ask them why do you attack rich
people so much don't you realize you
need them to pay for the poor people
[Music]
this is the Rubin report and I'm Dave
Rubin friendly reminder everybody to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
click that notification bell so you're
alerted when new videos come out and
joining me today is the former mayor of
New York City and a special guest star
of one of the best ever episodes of
Seinfeld Mayor Rudy Giuliani welcome to
the Rubin report
thank you very much dick so I could
basically spend I could spend an hour
talking to you about Seinfeld and
something bit on Saturday Saturday Night
Live but I know that there are probably
probably some more pressing things that
you want to get to but I thought what
would be interesting instead of just
going into all of the stuff of today
which we will get to is that especially
for my younger audience on YouTube that
that sort of know you as New York City's
mayor and and 9/11 that that version of
you you had a whole life and and a
political evolution before that that in
many ways is sort of like my political
evolution you you fought off the Mafia
as Attorney General and a whole bunch of
stuff so can we just do sort of Rudy
Giuliani 101 I mean really from
childhood childhood on and then we'll
get to the topics of the day I'll do it
real quick I was born in Brooklyn a
second-generation Italian American I
went to Catholic grammar school then I
moved from Brooklyn to Long Island which
was quite common in those days and
continued
Catholic around the school what Alex can
lead were you in yeah in Garden City and
North Bellmore Long Island two different
places and all yeah yeah but I went to
high school in Brooklyn Bishop Lachlan
High School which was a special diocesan
School in part because I wanted to be a
priest in my early days and kind of gave
that up when I found out there were
things called girls and I kind of didn't
work with the priesthood then I went to
college in the Bronx in Riverdale
Manhattan College law school at NYU
graduated law school and went became a
law clerk to a really fine federal judge
lloyd McMahon who taught me how to be a
tri war and then I entered the US
Attorney's Office at a very young age
and because of his training I thought it
started off as already a pretty
experienced trial water because he he
was a nice enough man to kind of teach
you what you have to do in the courtroom
and I love being a trial lawyer I spent
about five and a half years doing that
tried a hundred cases or so some mafia
cases bank robbery cases white collar
cases income tax evasion customs fraud
just about everything you can think of
they're federal crimes and then I was at
I was the head of the Narcotics Division
which in those days was focused a lot on
the French Connection the Italian French
heroin trade the Colombian trade all the
Colombian cartel people that was the
first time that somebody put out a
contract to kill me Vito Genovese his
brother-in-law
threatened to have me killed because I
prosecuted him and he got convicted the
Colombian cartel threatened to slit my
throat but I was like a 25 26 years old
and you know I don't know you feel
immortal in though in at a younger age
then I went off to Washington to be the
deputy chief of staff to the Deputy
Attorney General Harold Tyler
the Ford administration and that's where
I started to think about I had a pack
left the Democratic Party as an
assistant US attorney because I was
investigating a lot of corruption in
city government under John Lindsay and
even though John Lindsay was a
Republican who turned Democrat all the
people in city government would mimic
rats and all these great society
programs which I kind of thought sounded
nice it looked like none of it was
getting to the poor people it was all in
the hands of the administrator of the
program his wife some of the crooked
minority politicians in the city the
wife quickly came to realize didn't
really care about their community just
cared about getting rich for themselves
very disillusioned I changed my
registration from Democrat to
independent then I went off when I
worked for two years in the Ford
administration met a lot of Republicans
and found out that they really weren't
terrible my impression from New York
were you know Republicans only care
about rich people and they're really
very mean and turned out they were just
as caring about poor people they just
had a different way of trying to move
them out of poverty kind of made more
sense to me they can move people out of
poverty through work than welfare I kind
of had always a strong aggressive
foreign policy with regard to Soviet so
I was sort of a Kennedy Democrat in
those days there was a fellow named sue
Jackson a senator who was a very hard
liner on foreign policy so then I
switched to being a Republican I said
let me try the Republican Party when
it's a law practice works for Ronald
Reagan's election and Ronald Reagan made
me the third ranking official in the
Justice Department I did that it came
back to New York I became the US
Attorney I prosecuted the five families
to the Mafia over 800 mafia people a
large number of Wall Street criminals
Boesky probably being the most famous
one Milken prosecuted three or four
sitting congressmen and also started
using the racketeering statute in a way
that hadn't been used before to break up
organized crime who took over the
chamber
Union drove out organized-crime who took
over the casinos and most Vegas and got
rid of them we took over the Fulton fish
market the the whole industry of the
garment industry entertainment
entertainment industry Rangeley mafia
controlled the gay boss in New York and
a combination of our work and then the
advent of hiv/aids got rid of those
places but the Mafia owned those bars
for purposes of extortion owned every
single one you couldn't open a gay bar
in New York and not have Vito Genovese
and his his number two guy walk in on
you and tell you that he owned half the
bar today why and they stayed because if
we don't we break your will break your
kneecap so we got them out of there and
I had a very and then I catch this thing
that made me famous as as the mayor was
i prosecuted a number of the high-level
officials in the conch administration
its chief political allies and proved
that they were involved in a
multi-million dollar bribery scheme to
collect find and divert them to to their
own pocketbooks to the tune of about
fifteen or twenty million dollars a year
geez that gave me a great deal of name
recognition and I got the crazy idea and
run after mayor all my friends told me I
was nuts the Republican couldn't win I
thought maybe I was nuts but I was young
enough to try to be nuts and find out if
I would enjoy politics I was lucky
enough to get David Garth as my
political advisor I started off but 27
points behind I lost by two David taught
me how to be a political candidate and
it was the best showing a Republican had
made in 40 years since LaGuardia
I got 48% of the vote and I guess if I
had not in 20 I'd have given up but but
48% of the vote I spent to myself maybe
I can have another chance to do this and
then you eventually decided to do it
again and and the residents were you so
later four years later I did it again
and I won by a very narrow margin about
3% and then I ran for re-election four
years later I won by a landslide and I
was very fortunate I made a lot of
promises I really went into the job with
the notion that this is the first
Republican in two generations I might be
the last Republican mayor of New York
why not just do everything I wanted to
do and if I had worked I'd be a hero and
if it didn't they'd throw me out and
maybe 20 years later they realized I was
trying to do the right thing I really
had that attitude so I yeah
but city government I cut city
government to what it should be by about
20 percent
I laid off enormous numbers of people I
decrease everything in city government
interestingly but the police department
because I had I had couple years before
I before I was mayor we had two thousand
two hundred murders
and we had about 1.1 billion people on
welfare we had ten nine percent
unemployment and we had a deficit that
was said to be about 700 million a
trillion with 1.4 billion and we had a
situation with 75 percent of the people
in the city wanted to leave so I ran on
very much but the the things that Donald
Trump he is four years ago which I might
say I kind of suggested he I said you
can't do any worse
how can you out to New York's did he be
any worse been leading the country in
crime murder violent crime white-collar
crime organized crime drugs we were head
and everything how can we be any worse
than you know 1.1 million people not
working being supported by the other
people who are working no fortune 500
company in 20 years to come to New York
and about 20 have moved out and our tax
base was getting wrong and even movies
wouldn't be made in New York anymore
they were making the New York movies in
Toronto because they were too expensive
to make a New York in two days so I said
you give me a chance I know everything
is wrong with it I have 12 years of
experience putting all the bad guys in
jail maybe I can turn the knowledge of
everything's wrong with it and just
straightening it out and I all right
there's a but I hold my you know my job
shoots very specific plans to do yeah
all right so there's a couple different
ways we could go there so so first off i
mentioned to you when i was on your
podcast a couple days ago we have a sort
of similar history not only because of
the political evolution of sort of
democrat too independent to what you
know I would say I'm sort of like a
modern conservative at this point which
i think is sort of what you are even
even you know we're sort of in the same
spot even on abortion which is not
thought of as a conservative position
specifically but the the guy whose name
you actually didn't mention in there was
the guy that you replaced as mayor which
was David Dinkins who was a far left
progressive and he basically is the one
that that sort of wrecked New York City
and I remember going to New York City my
grandparents lived there and my
great-grandparents lived there
and you couldn't go to Times Square and
and you can do all of that you cleaned
all of that stuff up and I think a lot
of people right now are seeing what de
Blasio is doing with many of the same
ideas as David Dinkins and all these you
know the big government progressives
they're seeing that and I do sense that
maybe maybe there's another rudy
giuliani in the waiting but i got to
back up to something else you're a
second
you're a second-generation Italian
American and you went after the Mafia so
you got to explain that a little bit
more how did that just in terms of your
own ethnicity and identity how is that
well you know I I knew the Mafia from
growing up in Brooklyn and from being in
an Italian family I I was not one of
those people where you had to tell me
you know what is the Mafia I knew what
it was I knew its history from the black
hand when the italian-american
immigrants first came to this country
the turn of the century the black hand
would would prey on them I remember
stories in my family that my grandfather
who ran a large large Tavern in Coney
Island several times he was he was
required to pay money to the Mafia once
when he didn't they burn part of the
store I was told what bullies they are
how terrible they are though I had an
impression of them as being very bad for
the Italian people and then obviously
found out as I got older but there was
also a tremendous prejudice that every
Italian was part of the Mafia including
at times I would be told that I was part
of them off so it created both you know
both both sets of problems when I became
an assistant state's attorney it wasn't
really to pursue the Mafia it was to be
a trial war but I always wanted to be
all my life and to try all different
kinds of crimes but it just so happened
that that was the era in which the FBI
was just beginning to really go after
the Mafia J Edgar Hoover had always
preferred to go after communists than
the Mafia and I tried one big mafia case
as a young lawyer against a fellow named
Vito Gaggia his name was actually
his nickname was Peters they all have
nicknames he was the son-in-law of Vito
Genovese and we were allowed to
prosecute him because he cheated on
Vito's sister though Vito basically
liked the witness over the dead
witnesses the permission to testify
against and I had no idea why I had all
these witnesses testifying against this
big mafia guy in the middle of the trial
he threatened to kill me which because
he was a little bit nut so for the first
time I had to have protection and I
convicted him and it was a big
conviction but I think I had that
conviction you know thanks to Vito who
was willing to Attell three or four of
his loan shark victims it's okay to
testify against my brother-in-law
because he's screwing around on my
sister hey and then I left I went to
Washington I was one of the people that
helped establish the FISA Court so when
we litigate all this stuff about the
FISA Court Jo digenova who be on
television and I were the two lawyers
who helped develop the FISA Court I
dealt with the Church Committee I've
learned Washington came back to New York
I was in law practice and then I became
the third ranking official in the
Justice Department under Ronald Reagan
and that's where I really became
interested in politics because Reagan
was to me you know bigger than life just
a great great man just a natural
president natural leader and
unbelievably underestimated much like a
present president and a lot of his
success came than being underestimated
yeah so we'll get to our current
president in a little bit obviously
you've you've talked about you know what
9/11 was like many many times so maybe
sort of briefly I you know I I told you
this the other day I lived in New York
City on the Upper East Side during 9/11
my dad worked in the garment center he
saw the second plane hit I had my
grandma live there plenty of family
there we were all there and and truly
one of the things that I remember most
you know beyond the the tangible stuff
the smell that you could smell you know
for weeks and and all of that is that
you calmed everybody down and showed
actual true leadership in a time when we
needed it in an unimaginable way we do
you in many ways feel like everything
that you just laid out in these few
minutes sort of led you to that moment
yeah and when that when you got the call
I mean were you just ready to be a
leader in that moment you know strange
to say but yes and and to make it even
more of more direct I had just finished
the first draft of a book called
leadership somehow about a year before
I've been wanting to write a book
forever and ever I started three
different book I can never figure out
exactly what I wanted to write about and
something about a year before I got the
idea that I'd write about leadership
because I had been in a lot of different
leadership positions both in government
and in business I ran a coal mine once
there's a hold together different story
and got it out of bankruptcy so I
thought I would write about how I was
able to do that what at least the
lessons that I use to teach myself a new
business I haven't I have a sort of
general feeling that I'd rather have a
great manager than a subject-matter
expert in any situation because
management skills are sometimes part of
the fine then subject matter expertise
so the book talks about 20 lessons or so
on leadership so by the time September
11th happened it was in a it was at a
final draft form it was sitting in my
desk that's gonna publish it when I left
the mayor's office and then all the and
I probably probably the day before
September 11 I was pretty arrogant if
you would ask me you know could you
handle an emergency I'd say of course I
mean I've been the mayor of New York
it's a it's a crisis of week it's an
emergency a month and it's a
catastrophic emergency every six months
I mean we had hurricanes we had airplane
crashes we had subway derailment we had
hostage situations we had terrorist
attacks I mean every day was something
and I had developed the first mayor's
office of emergency management because
we had had a terrorist attack the year
before I came into office in 1993
probably another reason that elected me
is we were very poorly prepared for that
so I established a special mayor's
office of emergency management and all
they did was train us on how to get
ready for nuclear attack sarin gas which
was a big problem back then anthrax
which we actually did get attacked with
during a 9/11 we went through a West
Nile virus people don't remember that
but it was kind of a mini form of the
pandemic that we just went through so we
so so we were very skilled up and I
stayed we I had a great team we were
very skilled in emergency management
well the sudden 9/11 happens I arrived
there I look at the scene I see a man
throw himself out of the hunters floor
and I turn to my police commissioner
Bernie Kerik and I say Bernie we're not
prepared for this whatever we did this
challenge is everything we know and
we're gonna have to use our instincts
here and we don't have it we got 24
plans for emergencies we don't have one
that says the airplanes rushing into
buildings like torpedoes and we had to
make we had to make it up as we moved
along but the fact that we had that
experience kind of made it possible for
us to do that I think a little better
than might have been done if we hadn't
had that exploit I know this is probably
a little bit of an odd question but did
you realize at the time how important
just sort of remaining just the optics
of being in charge and being calm in it
were because that you know it felt like
I mean I remember being there it felt
like the world was over or nothing even
remotely close to normal was ever gonna
come back and every time I turned on CNN
you were there and you were in the
streets or wherever you were and it was
like oh somebody somebody's trying to
make some sense of this thing somebody's
in charge yeah I knew that on a smaller
scale I mean I didn't realize do you
normally of it
right away I thought of it as since I
had done so many emergencies in the city
it began for me as gigantic big way
beyond anything we did before but
involving my city but any part of
handling an emergency gives you control
your emotions and no matter how confused
you are no matter how afraid you are and
no matter how absurd one about somebody
dying you just control and you do a I
call it a Scarlett O'Hara I'll think
about it tomorrow yeah you know I
remember when went when I was first told
that father judge died he was the first
person whose body we found father judge
was my close friend eight years he was
the person that taught me how to deal
with death first time I was three
firefighters he was an extraordinary
Franciscan priest and I found out that
he died almost simultaneously with my
wanting to call my fire Commission
instead and today go get father judge I
needed meaning I needed him for advice
on how to explain the people at that
point we thought 12,000 people were dead
and as I'm thinking that my police my
fire commissioner walked in Tom von
essen and he says mayor we got a real
problem they're carrying father judges
body out of out of the rubble they're
taking him over to st. Peter's Church
that is he dead he said yes and I would
say if it hadn't been on I hadn't been
in the middle of it having to run it I
probably would have gone in a room and
cried for about 10 min because he was so
important but I had to say to myself
okay contain it stop it you'll figure
this out you'll figure you'll figure
this out tonight you'll figure out what
he taught you and you'll use it tonight
so I had been trained like that from
earlier emergencies that you just don't
show it you just you put aside the
emotion and you think about what's the
next practical thing that you have to do
in order to keep this thing under
control
yeah and and you did we could obviously
spend the whole hour talking about this
I just have one one other thing on this
and then we'll move on to some other
things you know because right now we
live in such a time where it seems like
everyone's so polarized and so hating
and all of that and and you know New
York City has the the the idea that we
all hate each other and you know I never
found New York City to be like that
actually we're kind of rough on the
outside but if you ask anyone for
directions they're happy to talk to you
usually but I do remember for a few
months after 9/11 there was like a
really special feeling on the street I
remember actually I told you I lived on
the Upper East and I went to play
basketball at the courts right by Gracie
Mansion on 90th the New York and you
know maybe make yeah maybe two or three
weeks after 9/11 and we were playing
basketball and you could still smell the
the soot in the air and all that and two
guys got into a fight and they were
about to punch each other like it was
about to happen and they both started
crying and basically everyone on the
court started crying at the same you
know all kind of teared up at the same
time that there was something so special
about that and I wonder well can you
just talk about that feeling after and
also do you think there's a chance we
can ever get back to something like that
for for as crazy as things seem right
now I hope that's still there Dave I
hope though it wasn't extraordinary
I'd say three four week it was like the
world had changed we were all friends by
all friends I mean Hillary Clinton and
Chuck Schumer and George Bush and the
Democratic congressman in the Republican
Congressmen they came as a group I took
them on a tour as a group these are
people that nowadays you know we're all
trying to put each other in jail and
well they were interested in was
legitimately interested in is how to you
know how can we help how can we get out
of this how can we how can we learn from
it very constructive I mean I got more
offensive help than I needed then I got
two very I got two really terrific calls
one from the governor of Florida Jeb
Bush and the other from the mayor of
Chicago Mayor Daley
and they both wanted to know if they
could send observers to watch so that
they could develop an emergency
management office like we had but when
it happens to them and they didn't say
if it happens to them instead but when
it happens to them and I thought that
was a very very very intelligent
decision to make
looking into the future then a few
others did that I think I've tried to
think of what's the difference between
that and then the pandemic where there's
a certain amount of unity that came out
of it but not for very long and it
quickly developed into almost a
political thing and into a political
thing I think not almost first of all I
think the difference is that an attack
on your country by a specific group of
foreigners or enemy is a very very
jarring thing that does bring you
together it's like somebody you're
feuding with your family members and
you're all at home fighting and then all
of a sudden people want to attack your
house and take the entire house with the
entire family
I think you'd get over the feeling they
put it aside for the same cause I think
a thing like the pandemic distil is more
diffused there were so many different
explanations for there was so much
confusion about it and contradiction
about it and then right away the attempt
to make political gain on it and it
didn't take a week or so of course I see
it from Republican eyes but for you know
Schumer and Pelosi to say that Trump
wasn't handling it right and he didn't
he didn't pick it up right away course
ignoring the fact that they didn't
either
he picked it up before they did right
[ __ ] she was inviting people to go out
and the idiot mayor here in the city for
two weeks they have to Trump declared it
was an emergency I was telling people to
go out yeah so there was plenty of
political blame to go around no
September 11 that probably was that
political blame also but everybody
stopped it and said you know it's stupid
all that political Fame was stupid
Pelosi didn't cause the pandemic and
neither the Trump and neither the
Schumer or Cuomo China did China caused
it and then we all reacted to something
that was extraordinary something new
something we didn't know about how did
they have reacted to it problem they
didn't know what this virus won't how
was foul see everyone says well spouse
he had about three different views on
well he did but he didn't know what it
was he may be a genius but he's not God
the same thing with September 11 I I the
people would criticize the reaction to
it and that's it
geez everybody's doing the best they can
this is something we never faced before
though you know I think we're doing a
pretty good job for something we didn't
face that existed was September it
doesn't exist now we go after the
pettiest little thing right away yeah
it's a it's a pretty hairy premise that
what could what we need potentially to
bring us together is is the unspeakable
but you know a few years after after you
left and you were no longer mayor I
don't think a lot of people remember
that you actually were gonna run for
Senator or you started running for
Senator from New York against Hillary
Clinton and then you were dying yeah you
were diagnosed with with prostate cancer
and then Rick Lazio who I think was just
a local politician in Long Island if I'm
not mistaken he stepped in and Hillary
obviously it was the member of tongue
news remember time member of Congress
right but but but obviously he didn't
make major waves where I think with you
and with you and Hillary it would have
been a real volatile but a great room
yeah do you ever think about that that
regardless of whether you would have won
or lost that history could have
absolutely changed because of that
election it could have I mean could have
changed sure yeah I don't mean yes yeah
sure sure you think about it and and but
I'm not I'm not I don't dwell a lot on
the things that didn't happen I'm sort
of dwell on the things that did happen
and did they happen right or wrong if
they happen rung how do we adjust them
so it happened
something that I wasn't meant to do and
and then I did run I did run for
president who tried to run against her
again and I lost and she lost oh we
never did get do yours ready well I
guess I guess I don't even have to ask
this question because you don't you
don't dwell on things but you know you
you sort of had this strategy that you
were gonna wait sort of for the big
stuff till Florida and then it just it
just didn't happen but I guess I don't
have to ask you if you regret it because
you don't dwell I don't regret it I
think I actually think when I look back
on it two things make it easy one I
think the strategy would not have worked
no matter how we did it
I was to moderate a Republican for them
to nominate look I'm the last nominee to
try to become the Republican candidate
for president who's at all pro-choice
and I'm you know three months approached
oh yeah I I'm one of those people who is
pro-life individually but I am willing
to say that other people have different
moral views about this and a woman
should have a three month period in
which to decide whether or not you know
she can have the baby I don't like that
I wish it were different
I offer when I was mayor I would offer
and everybody would the other side would
get very angry I'd offer adoption as an
alternative but then ultimately I think
it's the woman's choice and finally I
can't find it in my heart to put people
in jail for which is the only way you
can enforce it now
the whole of your abortion debate has
become not like crazy like everything
else does buts now we're talking about
abortion in the eighth months and we
have this crazy governor in Virginia who
is talking about abortion after the
baby's born post- literally yeah I don't
know if he's stupid he didn't know what
he said and it's too stubborn to go back
on it or he really means that you should
get a waiting period but the doctor and
the mother can talk over what to do with
the baby but there's nothing you can do
with the baby
except commit murder yeah yeah well it's
interesting
I'm glad you mentioned that I know I
know you read my book I take the 12-week
also so the three-month position and
that people will say to me well Dave you
know you seem to align with the
Conservatives on so many issues this is
the one that you don't really align with
them on and I'm actually fine with that
because I always find that the
Conservatives that disagree with us on
this they're always willing to talk
about it respectfully do you ever find
that they won't talk about it
respectfully versus on the other side
where if you don't agree you're done
yeah I mean it I'm not sure it was
always that way but the way the way it
is broken down now and I hope this isn't
my own prejudice I find far more ability
within the conservative movement
Republican movement to talk about our
disagreement without anger then on the
Democratic side for example when I was
running Mike Huckabee and I were running
against each other and after one debate
I think it was the third of fourth
debate him and we're good friends he
said to me you know mayor I'm a minister
and I have trouble even with your narrow
pro-choice position it would be hard for
me if I dropped out to endorse you in
the primary although I have to think III
he gave me some reasons why he thought
maybe I was the best candidate other
than him and I said well Mike and I'm
very impressed with you too he said and
the reason I would endorse you is
because you're honest about it
and he contrasted me with Romney who he
said it changed his position on
everything Romney had been pro-choice he
became completely pro-life Romney had
been for gun control he became a
lifetime member of the NRA Romney was
for gay right Romney was then totally
against even basic gay right not even
gay marriage or just you know you didn't
want gay rights to be included in any of
the civil rights laws that we had and he
had signed a similar bill like I did
that allowed for for partnership laws
there's more marriage one of the things
that was done was you could you know you
could protect yourself illegally by
becoming a civil partner and I think I
was the second a second official in
America to sign that and interestingly
that never caused me
in the Republican Party mm-hmm I used to
get endorsed every time I ran by the
gate by the gay Republican group called
a log cabin club and it was never as
hot-button an issue as abortion and I
think when you see how it played out it
played out without as much political
division yeah so let's let's move
forward to sort of what's going on today
because there's a lot of stuff happening
in our cities I know you're no fan of
your current mayor even though you still
live in New York City but de Blasio
seemingly has done a series of things
that the earth that are the exact things
that you were trying to clean up when
you became mayor so can you can you talk
a little bit about what it's like to
live in a city that you love that you
were the mayor of to watch it go
backwards and as you know I've mentioned
this the other day but I had I've at
times in in my family's history we had
dozens I think at one time something
around 50 family members at one time
that lived in New York City we now have
one person left my sister and her
husband and two kids just left over the
last two months I now have one second
cousin left that's it
after having a rich history in New York
City it kills me to say that but can you
talk about what's going on in New York
City right now and and maybe what you
would do to turn around some of this
stuff well first of all it's the status
I've ever been about New York City I'm
much more down about it than I was let's
say when I ran or even when I was US
Attorney I mean when I was he was
returning I wasn't sure I wanted to run
for mayor but I was seeing all the
things that were wrong with New York
City that's one of the 2000 murders a
year were taking place then the Mafia
had control of had almost every business
in this video when you couldn't build a
building you couldn't have your garbage
taken out without paying but I always
felt there was solutions to this there
were things that we could do and I
always felt there was the will there to
change it now I'm not maybe it's because
I'm not as involved in politics and I
don't go to the local groups as much I
feel that same desire to change it's
almost a hopelessness and I am also
witnessing many many of my friends
leaving I just drove back from the
airport early this morning earlier this
morning sorry about five or six moving
trucks and I'm kind of counting them now
because I had a friend come over last
night
tell me he's moving to Florida and these
are basically upper middle class and
wealthy people they the tax base of the
city and I've never wondered about you
know since maybe I stopped being a
liberal I I always ask them why do you
attack rich people so much don't you
realize you need them to pay for the
poor people and when I was the mayor of
the city my budget but budgets videos
you know larger than all but about ten
states
I need a tremendous amount of money to
take care of Medicare Medicaid of
welfare aid for children aid for
battered children all the things we do
the public hospital system New York City
provides universal health care through
its public hospital system only place in
America I think that does denim we've
been doing it for hundred and twenty
years though our bills are very high who
pays those bills Wall Street all those
beautiful apartments you see on Park
Avenue and and Fifth Avenue and that on
the west side now and every every time a
new area gentrified and the tax base
started to go up I would see it as I can
do more for people I can do I can I can
do more to make this city a little more
balanced in terms of rich and poor and a
little more opportunity for people to
move out of poverty because for me
there's no question that capitalism is
the only way out of poverty the rest of
it is a is a false program that's
presented to people by con so what would
you do when you know like little things
like that you can now jump a turnstile
at the subway and you know they won't
find you they won't stop you and then
now we see I mean there's videos every
day on Twitter you see 20 people do it
at once kids just open up the door you
know that the handicap accessible door
and just let tons of people in that that
in many ways de Blasio's plans which
sort of sound right or we want to help
people that are poor that's that's
always how it's sold actually encourage
lawlessness and then and then really
let's talk about just the the rioting
that's happening all over the city I've
got a friend I've got a friend who lives
on Spring Street who has abandoned New
York City he's got a great apartment he
hasn't been there in months and his
friend took a video from his apartment
and and all hell was breaking loose I
mean it truly look like a third world in
New York City you know when I was a
prosecutor for many many years
16 17 18 years I was a federal
prosecutor which meant I always tried
very big case by cases you don't try the
small cases as it local prosecutor you
you'll try the murder case and the the
theft case federal prosecutor you're
trying organized crime you're trying
very very intricate financial fraud high
enough level so it arises to federal
time I prop I was not a natural
proponent of the broken windows theory
didn't even make sense to me when it was
first told to me because I always
thought we paid too much attention to
the small things not enough attention is
a big crime and it was taught to me by
about 1981 when I was the associate
attorney general the United States we
established a commission on violent
crime and professor James Q Wilson was
the vice chair of it and I got very
close to Professor Wilson who developed
this theory at Harvard with with
Professor Kevin and what he tried to
explain to me was first of all you're
not an expert on street crime I'm gonna
make you one you're an expert on
bi-level climb even mafia crime is high
level crime but look let's take a look
at street crime that's what you did for
to you he said it also a lot of awful
lot of it has to do with what the young
people see
in the community and let's make it he
said let's make it really simple if they
see a lawful community where the
expectation is that you don't ruin other
people's property by putting a graffiti
all over that you have to pay when you
go through the turnstile if you take
something from someone you have to give
it back
well there are punishments for that he
said if society is based on that you
have very little big brunt reverse it if
the society looks like your New York
where everything is filled with graffiti
as if somebody's property doesn't mean
anything where you don't have to pay for
the turn-turn stuff where you can spit
on the sidewalk where you can urinate in
the street where you can do anything you
want the attitude begins at a very early
age that there there are no limits there
are no restriction and by the time you
start to get to the big crime it's
really too hard to deal with so I even
translated that into my theory of how
you stop a riot
which they fails to do this time and we
never fail to do it if you stop a riot
before it is a run you anticipate you
see a protest wonderful things protest
people have a right to call me names
call you names whatever they want to do
but I used to these to give him a
lecture because I had to Jenkins had so
many protests I just had to stop it oh I
wasn't gonna have any no I gave a speech
and I said let's understand each other
you can have all the protests you want
I'm Pro First Amendment they can do
anything you want protested however the
minute you throw around you can go to
jail you're not gonna get arrested you
gotta go to Rikers Island
I'll let you sit there for a day before
even taking for a judge if you scratch a
car you're gonna get arrested if you
burn anything I'm gonna try to put you
in jail for a long time and if you
physically harm someone we're talking
five six seven eight years and if your
I won't treat you as a juvenile two
years an adult so I'm gonna be really
really nice to you if you have a
peaceful protest I'm gonna protect you
I'm gonna make it easy for you to do it
and I don't really care what you say you
can call me a Nazi you can call me
whatever you want but it isn't gonna be
the last act of criminality it's the
first one we're going to go after
because David Dinkins had a theory he
called venting and it caused the Crown
Heights and the Washington Heights riots
they let it go on for three days and by
the time Ray Kelly had to solve it in
Crown Heights many many Jewish people
have been one had been killed many have
been beaten with kind of a pogrom the
same thing in Washington Heights and
that's essentially what happened to us
you know in all those democratic cities
in Minnesota they didn't enforce the law
for three or four days in New York I
mean I have pictures of people going
into stores walking out with television
walking out with liquor and the cops are
watching cops are not observers of crime
but not there to record the crime I've
been there to stop it can you talk a
little bit about the more difficulty
they had exactly I maintain that these
riots in part were caused by the boy
mayor of Minneapolis who let them take
over the police precinct once he let
them take over a police precinct that
affects everybody all over the country
all these ante for groups black lives
matter groups and man let's see if we
can push our Police Department like that
and what they found were and I say this
not to be partisan just to be accurate
they found that to be true in democratic
cities the Democratic mayor's were
afraid to confront them because they
were afraid of the base going against
they made a political calculation about
the enforcement of the law rather than
protecting their citizens that's
disgraceful
yeah can you talk a little bit about the
tension that exists right now between
the New York Police Department and de
Blasio cuz I've got a couple contacts
there
who I mean they're ready to revolt
against the guy like it is a
extraordinary mess right now
they believe that his incompetence puts
their lives at risk they believe that
his big mouth is condemning of them
if this goes back to the very beginning
with two police officers called Ramos
and Liu when there were riots in
Baltimore and de Blasio shooting his big
mouth off said something about our
Police Department also having problems
and racism he didn't reflect on the fact
that his Police Department is not a
majority white police department anymore
that combination of Dinkins Koch and me
we gave Lumbergh a non majority anything
Police Department and Bloomberg made it
even better and we were all pretty proud
of that
but instead of made making that point
which might have helped keep the problem
away from us he wants to put us in with
you know if there are racist police
departments braces placed above within a
few days of that a crazy man from
Baltimore comes up to New York two
police officers Ramos and Liu was
sitting there guarding a housing
development protecting black people and
the guy puts the bullet in the back of
both of the heads so the police
department surmised whether fair or not
is why would he have thought in New York
his big mouth hadn't made this statement
and that's the time they turned their
back on him told him they didn't want
him coming to the Pharaoh didn't want
him coming to the and then it's been a
series of unfortunate statements that
he'll stay he had to teach his son how
to deal with the danger presented to him
by the New York City Police Department
he didn't mention the fact that the
really should have taught us on how to
deal with the danger presented him by
other black young men I mean the police
department is chance of being touched by
the police department in comparison to
being killed by a black man in New York
you know is is less than 1% as opposed
to 75% of the murder victims in New York
City
a black and 75% of the murderer's a
black so I mean you got to be a stupid
father just to train your father it's
none too worried about the police one by
a factor of about fifty to one he's much
more likely to be killed by another
young black man do you think the average
New Yorker is waking up to this and
seeing the chaos on the streets and and
everybody you're talking about yeah yeah
do you think a Republican or a
conservative could ever win in New York
again we're at the point where
Republican independent or reformed
Democrat you know somebody that's
completely removed from the political
machine yeah it's so helpful that I
could not have done what I did in New
York I'd have been a Democrat I hadn't I
owe no one a John thing nothing like I
could get rid of 20,000 people in city
government and the unions could go crazy
none of them supported me I didn't
expect them to support me in the future
I think I would have done it anyway but
I'm not sure takes a lot of courage to
do that but I had to make so few
compromises if any to become mayor that
I mean I guess I didn't think I'd even
be so I was like free as a bird to do
what I wanted and the few people that
did help me they really were helping me
because they were so fed up with the
city the one thing they wanted from me I
knew if I reduce crime I was gonna be a
successful mayor I knew I was a
one-issue man I also knew if I didn't
reduce crime they'd throw me out now we
turned out to do a lot of other things
we reduced welfare by six hundred
thousand people we got rid of
homelessness we set up a whole new thing
for administration for Children Services
and dealt with domestic violence much
much better than ever before and we
reduced taxes by 35% which had never
been done in New York City my first tax
reduction was only 3% my deputy mayor
came to me he said may instead of
the tax reduction computer that's
impossible only 3% and then my he was my
best friend he also laughed at me is
that it's only tax reduction ever even
LaGuardia was the liberal that tells you
everything remarkable things but the the
crime reduction was the thing that made
everything possible once they saw we
could do the impossible they had
confidence in us to do the normal
political things that could be done if
you were mayor of Seattle right now and
there was an autonomous zone or whatever
they're calling it gets renamed every
day right but there was a zone in your
city that was in effect a lawless zone
that police cannot go to in any
effective way that you know people can
do whatever they want they've taken over
stores and public parks and everything
else
what would you do today because the
mayor in effect she's basically saying
it's lawful it's fine and Trump's stay
out of the way and in many ways I think
she's trying to set up I think between
her and Inslee the the governor of
Washington they're trying to set up a
trap they're showing hey we progressives
let anyone do whatever they they want so
the whole place is gonna crumble and
trump's gonna have to send in troops or
the National Guard or something and then
they'll say see he's the exact
authoritarian we always said he was what
was the only word the mayor first of all
it's inconceivable me that we'd be at
that point because the first time they
put up a barricade and my police
couldn't go in would be the last time
they did it there I'll be sitting in
jail though they wouldn't be around if I
had to come in now if they put me in
charge of that city right now with the
barricades there I would make an
assessment of what I needed to get rid
of them and I would get rid of them at
the earliest possible moment and I would
tell them I think if I were you I would
leave because it's gonna be much more
pleasant if you leave than if I have to
make you leave but don't don't mess
around with me because I'm not joking
I'm not one of these silly wussy liberal
mayor's like make my day
give me a chance to get you out of there
and I'll get you out of it you're not
paying taxes
you're not helping my city the smoking
dope like crazy maybe I'd sent DEA in
first and wipe out the drug deal then I
get about half of them out and it'd be
easier in fact think maybe if I were the
US Attorney there I would send the Drug
Enforcement Administration in and do a
major raid and get all the cocaine meth
marijuana
I know it's legal in Washington not
legal in the United States of America
somehow I do know I feel a deal with
organized crime you got to take
advantage of laws like the tax evasion
laws and in order to accomplish
something but if you want to make the
problem easier for the uniformed police
lovers they don't take a look at all the
federal crimes they're committing and go
in and go in with a federal task force
and arrest them Drug Enforcement
Administration's a tough outfit I'd you
know I don't think they've encountered
something like a statement police by the
Seattle police they haven't encountered
the Drug Enforcement Administration yeah
I want a shift animal so I want a shift
to trump a little bit because obviously
you guys are friends you have a history
so I want to know a little bit about
just the history of when he was just a
real-estate developer before he was even
a reality TV host but what that was like
when when you were mayor and you knew
him but also I mentioned this to you
last week that the when I was at Marlo
go right before Christmas you guys were
sitting at the table right next to us
unfortunately I didn't get to say hi to
you but this was right when impeachment
was blowing up and everybody in the news
was saying the walls are closing in
Trump's freaking out this whole thing
but I'm watching the two you had a
corner of my eye
Trump has no tie on you guys are
laughing up a storm having a ball and
everybody saying the guy's freaking out
and then I had a very nice day but can
you just talk a little bit about Trump
well first of all he never freaked out
during the whole experience
there's even an article in The
Washington Post I mean you want to talk
about fake news
there's an article that one day Jay
Sekulow who is my co-counsel and I were
there with with several other lawyers
and the president had lost it and he
started throwing papers around and he
threw something at Jane Raskin who was
one of our lawyers and I kept back we
get back to our office and the
Washington Post has disbarred but first
of all he didn't throw anything around
number two Jane wasn't even at the
meeting there were no women at the
meeting but the report have wanted it
that he liked he assaulted a woman would
have been I said why don't you make any
threw it at me at least I was there he
didn't throw it at me but you can see
there but they don't they don't like
they don't like they just throw nothing
at you but they made up yeah yeah I mean
you can't believe how cynical I became I
began I began representing him thinking
that Muller was a fair guy I knew him
two years I mean he worked he worked
under me in the Justice Department and I
worked with him on 9/11 and he was kind
of a rookie he had just become director
of the FBI I always thought of him as a
fair man
I got very worried you know from the
outside when he started hiring all these
political operatives because having been
a prosecutor you don't do that
you don't do that for the credibility of
your investigation I mean if they hired
me to investigate Hillary I wouldn't go
out and hire her were her worst enemy
or if somebody else was a pregnant to
investigate Hillary they wouldn't hire
me to go investigate because I made some
pretty harsh statements about they're
gonna try to find and in the prosecution
field you can find a lot of apolitical
people good I would though I say I said
to me either either Moore is losing
something or because the media lets them
get away with things they don't let us
get away with they're becoming very
sloppy because had a Republican put
together that kind of a group to
investigate Hillary
you know Joe Biden that have been wholly
held a pen mm-hmm no people who
contributed to the campaign people who
made statements that he was insane
people that made statements that he had
to be stopped under all circumstances
they shouldn't be on a prosecution for I
thought gee bob has kind of lost it a
little no when I came into the came into
the case and I had my first meeting with
him and he didn't even know whether he
had the whether he could indict the
president or not he had to go look it up
I said this guy's really let that become
lazy he didn't realize that he he had
Hillman I didn't realize that the guy is
suffering from some kind of a cognitive
brain impairment where he can't seem to
remember things or be on top of things
and after that three-hour meeting that
was the last time we saw him they kept
him locked under lock and key
kind of like what they're doing with
Biden that's that's exactly what I was
just gonna say um what about Trump
before all of this because obviously you
guys have become allies now and you
spoke at the convention of course and
all that stuff but just from the pre
Trump when he used to be a media darling
when he was just a New York City
businessman whether you liked him or not
that's what he was are you shocked it's
sort of just the way everything is
framed these days no I'm not I'm not
shocked I'm not you know I'd have to go
through a long story to tell you the
whole evolution I expected unlike you
know the popular conception that he
would be a good president and I also
thought he would probably get a lot of
credit more than he gets because he
would defy expectations kind of like
Reagan did you know they all thought
Reagan was a big dope and Reagan was one
of the presidents who probably was the
best writer I always tell people to go
read his love letters to Nancy did you
find out what a good writer he was but I
used to help write speeches for him and
I was shocked at what a good writer he
was because I had the prejudice from
Northeast that he was just an actor but
I knew the Trump had a very very facile
mind very very
complex mine had a very great interest
in politics and public affairs
you know his interest in trade goes back
30 years his idea of our intervening too
much goes back 20 years though these are
things you would talk to him about and
because I was in politics the two things
I talked to him about most will golf no
Dolf baseball and politics and we became
friends really because when I ran in
1989 I was going against Ed Koch he
thought Ed Koch was had become a very
bad mayor and he supported me and every
one of my political campaigns we became
good friends I joined his golf course my
son turns out to be a fabulous golfer
professional for a while he and me and
the president golf together a lot they
became very close and Donald became like
an uncle to Angela though it's through
them how nice he's been to my son that I
feel I can see the personal side of him
and I also saw him bring up his children
and he's a remarkably good father though
I see a side of him that people don't
stay he was also always there when we
had police officers in trouble
firefighters in trouble he George
Steinbrenner there's a whole group of
New Yorkers that somehow were painted is
maybe because they were more
conservative or they were more
Republican they were painted as some
kind of ogres and they really were very
very kind and very philanthropic and you
could count those finally the thing I
liked about Trump is he wasn't a
complainer but the mayor has to award a
lot of projects and I the spookiest
event everybody supported me in the real
estate area by anybody I gave it to it
could have been considered a political
favor though I would set up committees
to make the decision I would only
reverse them if they made a really
stupid decision and invariably my
friends would be cut out and they would
come to me and complain and then I would
say to them
you support me because he wanted a
low-crime good i said hasn't your
property value gone up to 30% because
the crime went down yes isn't that good
enough they would say no that project he
never did that and I turned him down for
the biggest project that I had which was
the Time Warner building because we
thought somebody else's design was
better he never once complained about it
though this idea that he's always
looking for advantages and it's not true
he he he negotiates in a way that looks
like he's gonna squeeze out every but
then then he's very very careful to stay
within the rules
he always had very good attorney the
best very good accountants I I don't
have an issue with everybody thinks oh
my god if they found his tax returns
they're gonna find all this I mean I
know every ordered I know how it came
out
they're gonna find nothing you know what
they will find is they'll find a lot of
money which you just can't prejudice
somebody with well look at all the money
he had but right nothing for that right
having money isn't illegal just yet just
yet
all right so I thinking of probably
that's fine but you're gonna probably
find a group of tax returns that you
could use in a tax course about how to
do it right because that's what he came
for
yeah well in many ways it's usually that
they're more pissed about the rules
whether the rather than whether someone
broke them and and and that we can
usually agree on yeah let's clean up the
tax code but that's a that's a whole
other thing so I got one more thing for
you that'll sort of segue to the end
here which is I mentioned at the
beginning yet you did the episode of
Seinfeld with the yogurt you you did
SNL where you were where you were in
drag those things seemed so distant
culturally from where we're at now
culturally like SNL would never put you
on now if there was a Seinfeld now
right right right because you're a
Republican and and you know if there was
a hot sitcom now there really isn't
anything but if there was the number-one
sitcom now it would never paint you as a
nice guy the way they painted you now
and I just thought maybe this could sort
of take us to the end which is as you've
seen the culture thing shift as a guy
that was on the other side of it and and
now you're more viewed as you know this
by mainstream let's say is like the
scary Trump Republican sort of thing how
is that for you personally and then just
also as a guy that's kept us calm
through some pretty terrible times
give me something hopeful give the
audience something hopeful over these
next couple months because I sense
people are really worried that that
things aren't gonna get back to anything
that looks like America from literally
four months ago well first of all I I am
very down about the idea we've been so
segmented and so stratified that even my
I mean Lorne Michaels is a good friend
of mine I spit right behind him at the
Yankee games I used to go on Saturday
Night Live all the time I haven't been
invited now the 10 for 10 for 10 years
and I think I was pretty good I was
pretty funny I've had posted her posted
an entire show I have a secret desire to
be an actor I always wanted to be an
actor I guess that's why I was a trial
where I was in I was in anger management
and out of towners and yeah a lot a lot
of the Lauren order stuff so I played I
played the Beast and Beauty and the
Beast
well kinds of roles I used to love doing
that I'm glad I got the chance to do it
because now you're right I would not
have the chance to do it here's what I
think is hopeful I think we're very very
lucky and I really mean this we're very
very lucky to have a president with an
indomitable spirit some of the president
given what he went through could be
broken by I mean Nixon became an alcohol
during the impeachment Pietschmann thing
or at least it's rumored that he did it
could have broken another man we're very
lucky that he has an indomitable spirit
because that'll eventually prevail if
once we get past a panda
once this calms down will it always does
it's going to get back to the economy
and how we're functioning in jobs and
he's gonna do miracles with it I mean
he's got a remarkable understanding of
our economy some of the things that he's
been able to do really means that the
next recovery can be faster and stronger
than the last one particularly in boxing
out China so much though I see it as
they'll be a rebirth the real question
is if he gets reelected which I think he
will and if he gets reelected with a
good spirit of the economy at least
coming back well the Democrats give him
at least two years before we go into the
next election and somebody should get
down on their hands and knees and beg
them to do that for the good of the
country
I think we know the answer to that one
well maybe maybe maybe if they get
defeated maybe they're gonna have to
reform their party that's the only way
they're gonna get fixed the only way
they're gonna get fixed was the way they
got fixed in the 80s or 90s when they
finally nominated Clinton and he did the
sister souljah moment they had been
going so far to the left that we were
trouncing and Clinton although maybe he
was more or less than he indicated or
certainly Hillary was Clinton made a
pretty good show in 92 that he was a
moderate candidate and he was after all
a governor of a conservative state so he
knew how to work with concern it was it
was in his DNA to work with right-wing
senators and Assemblyman and he always
knew how to do that I mean I had a great
relationship with Clinton I helped to
pass the infamous crime bill of 1994
with him and I have a great letter
explaining what a terrific mayor I am I
was going to use that if I ever ran
against Hillary well listen mr. mayor
I'm thrilled that you joined us for this
you're one of the last heroes that we
have in America that actually what they
believe in you you are that's the New
Yorker so I listen thank you so much
gracious and stay safe in New York all
right
I will sir you too if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell